- Alright everybody,
We've got one more story
of happiness before we say goodbye.
This is, What I'm Liking.
At weddings it's usually a
bad idea to upstage the bride
except in this next case,
it happened in Pennsylvania.
The daughter of the
bride stole the show when
she surprised the groom
with papers that would
allow him to adopt her,
so get your tissues ready?
- I've waited 2,555 days for this moment.
Frank, will you be my dad?
- Yeah
(clapping)
- It's so beautiful.
We have that family dialed in.
So everybody say hi to Frank and Tia
and their daughter Arianna.
Hi y'all!
Oh my gosh. I have to like look away
and like, not pay attention.
So I don't cry again.
It's such a beautiful video.
So, Frank
what were you thinking when
Ariana stepped forward?
- It was a roller coaster of emotions.
I thought I had everything
planned out, but when it hit me
the only thing I could
do is get ye, yeah out.
And it just happy to
make everything formal.
We, I always consider her my
my daughter from day one.
Just pure happiness.
- Aw. So Ariana,
you were specific, you said 2,555 days.
So what's the significance of that number?
- That was seven years from my mom
and Frank being marry, I mean together.
And I just always called him dad,
because he was always there for me.
And he was the only one there.
- That is so cool.
I'm so glad that doesn't
happen for everyone.
So it's such a beautiful
thing that this worked out.
I'm so happy for you, Ariana.
I'm so happy for you, Tia too
and to you as well, Frank.
Thank y'all so much
for sharing this story.
I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all, our
season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor ultimate overachievers
just like your lovely family.
So they're gonna give y'all
a thousand dollars just
for being great.
Thank you guys so much.
Have a blessed life together.